al ver el vídeo pasado a lo mejor te
surgió una duda ya platicamos de que la
función puede ser cóncava hacia arriba
en una región y parecer un agua o bien
ser con capas y abajo en otra y parecer
como una boca abajo sin embargo hay un
punto especial en el cual cambiamos de
tipo de concavidad verdad en el cual en
este ejemplo nuestra derivada pasó de
ser decreciente a ser creciente que no
ese punto debería de tener algún nombre
especial pues sí si piensas que lo
debería tener estás totalmente en lo
correcto a este punto especial en donde
la función pasa de ser cóncava hacia
abajo a ser cóncava hacia arriba o bien
en este punto en el cual la derivada
pasa de ser decreciente a ser creciente
o bueno donde la segunda derivada pasa
de ser menor que cero a ser mayor que
cero se le conoce como punto de
inflexión punto de inflexión
y pnv le sale entonces bueno un punto de
inflexión así por definición es un punto
en el cual se cambia el tipo de
concavidad de concab hacia abajo a
cóncavo hacia arriba pero bueno la mejor
forma de encontrar esos puntos y bueno
un criterio para encontrar esos puntos
es ver donde la segunda derivada donde
la segunda derivada cambia cambia de
signo del signo eso usualmente quiere
decir que se hace cero y por tanto que
hay un punto crítico en la derivada y
eso se refleja como un punto de
inflexión acá arriba vale entonces ese
es un criterio para encontrarlo y bueno
claro aquí tuvimos el caso en el cual
este digamos la segunda derivada pasó de
ser negativa a ser positiva pero también
podríamos tener que empiece siendo
positiva y pase a ser negativa como se
vería una gráfica así pues en vez de
parecer que como una n ahora parece como
como una cosa de este estilo si empieza
a ser así
y luego continúa haciendo algo de este
estilo vale entonces aquí que sucede
pues sí efe si la función f se ve así
esto quiere decir que primero la
derivada es creciente si se empieza
haciendo muy negativa y crece y crece y
crece y después la derivada empieza a
ser decreciente entonces eso como se
traduce a la segunda derivada pues la
segunda derivada primero es positiva
porque la derivada es creciente entonces
déjame escribirlo por acá tenemos
también que ese doble prima mayor que
cero y bueno aquí es creciente y de este
lado tenemos que f doble prima es menor
que cero y por tanto aquí también
tenemos un cambio de signo en la segunda
derivada y también se le conoce a una
situación así como que aquí tenemos un
punto de inflexión vale punto d
lee
sí muy bien